meanwhile in Ukraine more drone attacks
have taken place in the northeastern
city of kharkiv the police chief says a
college dormitory was hit in the early
hours of Tuesday authorities say other
densely populated areas of the city were
also targeted including a sports center
a 63 year old security guard was injured
and has been taken to hospital well in a
moment we'll hear from Ali Hashem in
donets but first let's start with step
vassen who's in karkif
authorities have confirmed that five
Shahid drones have hit the city of Park
even the early hours of the morning and
one of the buildings hit was this
odometry where students normally would
live but at the moment there was nobody
according to the authorities most of the
students are now studying online but as
you can see the damage is really really
bad and this is just one location two
other locations in hockey have been hit
as well a very populated area in the
city center was hit one of the security
guards got injured and this is really a
sign that the attacks coming from Russia
have been intensified especially in the
last couple of days Kaki saw a record of
Air Raids in the last 24 hours and also
a residential area was hit in trivia on
Monday where people died and many many
got wounded so this is what people in
Ukraine are experiencing right now
step class and Al Jazeera cap Cube
so let's speak now to Ali Hashem who's
live for us in Donetsk and Ali there has
been intense fighting overnight just
bring us up to speed on what we know
well so hell um the latest is from
marikov where we've heard that the
Ukrainian forces are sending
reinforcements there and there are more
attacks in an attempt to squeeze on
separagia now the chief of general staff
Russian chief of general staff usimov is
right now in Zappa Rogers as we saw in
some pictures that circulated from the
defense Ministry in accordance there
were Fierce fighting in the uh southern
city of marinka also towards Barkwood
north of dunyesk there are also reports
of fighting the city where we are
dunyesque saw several shellings in
different neighborhoods in kievsky in
petrovsky in karovsky
around the central of the city we are in
the center of the city the verashovsky
neighborhood that was hit yesterday with
several shells and around four people
were killed and several injured this
comes also as a pattern there have been
several attacks on on this city the same
place where we are close to the interior
Ministry witnessed also a missile Attack
Just couple of days ago and the
situation here is tense and this can be
seen and how things are around us but
the main issue is that the front lines
are witnessing Fierce battles and this
is part of this war that's going on
along the front line between Ukraine and
Russia
thank you